yes I did vote for the compassion Abuse
Act I was like you can keep your
morphine when I go outside and look I
don't want another pill do you get I
don't want another pill am I the only
person out of 4 million that doesn't
support this marijuana dispensary
madness so I stand here today as someone
is going to die because City Council and
other legislative members can't clarify
the laws for people like me well the
rest of the country was preoccupied with
the biggest economic downturn since the
Great Depression the medical marijuana
industry in Los Angeles exploded
estimates vary but there may be as many
as 800 dispensaries open for business in
LA that's more than the number of
Starbucks in the city in ordinance
recently passed by the LA City Council
however is about to change all that
today it's easy to gain access to
medical pot in California even if you
suffer from something like depression or
anxiety once you've got a recommendation
from a doctor you can go to weed babcom
and choose a dispensary near you and
when you arrive at a dispensary helpful
staffers are on hand to tell you all you
need to know about their products most
beautiful flowers it's an indica
dominant hybrid but it's pretty mellow
and relaxing so you can use it all day
this is the closest thing to marijuana
legalization our country has seen since
the 1930s and that's got people on the
front lines of the pot wars concerned we
have people in the area that are you
know teaching at the school is la high
right down the street and we started
hearing antidotal evidence of well you
know the marijuana is showing up at the
schools on Pico we found out well
there's 14 of them there and then I
found that there were a couple up on
Wilshire so it was like women what's
what what's going on I'm very concerned
that you know who knows who's running
some of these are these the same
characters that I would like to see put
out of business which are the gangs city
attorney Carmen treat a niche is worried
that nobody is testing them
marijuana's in LA just assumed that
there's a salad in front of you and I
just did this know what any of you eat a
salad with that sprayed on it
District Attorney Stephen Cooley
believes that dispensaries that sell
marijuana to patients aren't true
collectives and are therefore in
violation of state law vast vast vast
majority five hundred percent of
dispensaries in Los Angeles County in
the city are operating illegally there
are none that are operating legally in
LA County
none that we know of and that's a big
concern for medical marijuana activists
like Don Duncan of Americans for safe
access I'm discouraged to see a sort of
political posturing from the district
attorney's office and to a certain
extent from the City Attorney's Office
that it speaks more to their bias and
their opinion about medical cannabis
vendor their responsibilities to the
city 13 years after Californians passed
The Compassionate Use Act there's still
a great deal of uncertainty about what's
legal and what's not when you hear mr.
Cooley talk you're mr. Tanner talk or
you you talk to an average police
officer that you know I talk to all the
time they just want some clarity of
course dispensary owners like Daniel
Sousa have been operating in a legal
gray area for years and we've never had
a law enforcement issue never had a raid
you know not kind of would that either
collective so we're lucky in 2007 there
were at least 50 raids in Los Angeles
2008 there were several dozen in 2009
it's still continuing and no one has a
bigger stake in the pop wars than the
seriously ill people who benefit from
medical cannabis Carla Bailey is the
co-chair of the Los Angeles Commission
on HIV when I got my diagnosis in 95 I
was so sick from AZT I couldn't explain
it to people if I tried I got smart
though my niece came home she said I
didn't come with we she won up my
kolavari who suffers from muscular
dystrophy moved to California from New
Jersey on the recommendation of his
doctor he said my legal recommendation
to you is to move to California because
if I tell you to do anything else I'll
get arrested and so are you
I mean I left all that to come here and
now I'm here because they're talking
about shutting it down
so how exactly did we get here in 1996
Californians passed prop 215 which
legalized the medicinal use of marijuana
the only problem was that marijuana
medicinal or otherwise was still illegal
in the eyes of the federal government
when medical marijuana dispensary
started opening a few years later the
Drug Enforcement Administration raided
them but despite the risk dispensaries
continued to open concerned about the
proliferation of dispensaries the LA
City Council passed in interim control
ordinance in 2007 nearly 200
dispensaries registered with the city
and a moratorium was placed on new
dispensaries however a hardship
exemption in the ordinance created a
loophole that hundreds of medical pot
entrepreneurs have exploited over the
past two years in 2009 Attorney General
Eric Holder instructed federal
prosecutors to stop targeting medical
marijuana patients and caregivers who
are in compliance with state law which
brings us to January 26 of this year
when the LA City Council passed an
ordinance regulating medical marijuana
dispensaries in the city the goal was to
bring clarity to the medical marijuana
industry but at this point the only
thing that's clear is that the
transitional process will be difficult
under the ordinance several hundred
dispensaries that opened after the 2007
moratorium will be forced to close I
don't know if they really have the
resources to close that many down at
once they haven't demonstrated that they
do unfortunately they will make examples
of people and we're gonna have some good
people tangled up with the bad people
who are prosecuted in that if that
happens new zoning restrictions create
buffer zones between dispensaries
sensitive u s-- areas such as schools
and residences the new rules will force
all but a few of the remaining 137 pre
moratorium dispensaries to relocate and
the question as to whether the sale of
medical marijuana and dispensaries
complies with California state law is
something that will have to be worked
out in the courts whatever happens it's
clear that virtually everyone involved
in the debate wants to make sure that
people with serious illnesses like
cancer and AIDS
have access to medical marijuana many
people however are skeptical of the
claims of other so-called patients is it
you're a criminal sir no I'm not because
I am I'm actually under the influence of
medical marijuana actually a doctor
prescribed was it dr. Dre so what's the
deal is medical marijuana just the
gateway policy to marijuana legalization
you know it is a stepping stone towards
towards legalization you can't really
deny that it is while arrest for most
crimes in California have decreased
marijuana arrests are on the rise it's
no coincidence that the Volstead Act was
repealed in the middle of the depression
you have to make your you have to make
choices here just like in 1933 when
Prohibition was repealed Californians
today are wondering why the government
is wasting so much money on a war that
can't be won that's one of the biggest
reasons that I'm in favor of change
changes his drug laws because we don't
have the money California Assemblyman
Tom Ammiano recently introduced a bill
to tax and regulate marijuana in the
state the bill is being taken seriously
in part because California is facing a
twenty billion dollar budget deficit
regulating marijuana like alcohol would
save taxpayers hundreds of millions of
dollars in enforcement costs and it
would generate more than a billion
dollars in tax revenue and if
politicians in Sacramento don't change
the law California voters will have an
opportunity to legalize pot in November
extreme university is sponsoring a
statewide ballot initiative for 2010 to
legalize for adult use just a few years
ago pot legalization was nothing more
than a pipe dream
is marijuana legalization really a
possibility our country needs
legalization
I'd say within the next couple next
couple three years for sure we'll find
we'll find marijuana legalized I'm all
in favor of what everybody's doing and
trying to decriminalize it I will vote
for it but that's the way this country
works and I think one of the things that
makes it great I'm very optimistic that
we will be the first state to legalize
cannabis in California and I'm very
proud to be a part of the movement
consider this in 1996 prop 215 passed
with 56% of the vote
what percentage of Californians are in
favor of marijuana legalization today
you guessed it
56% for Reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie
[Music]